So the question was positive emotions
mediated by dopamine.
When you're advancing toward something,
say,
or when you have a cue that something
good is about to happen,
what is the system that mediates
positive emotion at the satiation level?
Negative.
Yup.
Okay.
Well,
let's start with the satiation issue.
That seems most deregulated by
Serotonin.
The opiate issue is there are other
forms of specific reward that don't seem
to be merely motivated or merely
underpinned by dopamine,
and the opiate system would be one of
those.
There's an oxytocin system as well,
so there are other biochemical systems
that are involved in more specific forms
of reward,
but the thing that's common among
instances that make it appear that
you're moving forward is the
dopaminergic element,
roughly speaking,
and then one of the things that happens
if you're higher in Serotonin because
you're more dominant,
is that you're more satiated all the
time.
That's why people who are low in the
dominance hierarchy with decreased
levels of Serotonin are more impulsive
and also more emotionally dysregulated.
They're more impulsive because,
hey,
you take your positive thing when you
can get it,
and so they're.
They're more dissatisfied,
they're more looking for anything that
will produce a positive outcome,
and then they're also more likely to
experience negative emotion,
partly because their serotonin systems
are lower,
indicating their tenuous status in the
dominance hierarchy,
meaning that everything they do that's
uncertain is far more dangerous.
So this is also why it's very difficult
often when you're trying to treat
someone who's depressed because you
could say there's not much difference
between being depressed and existing in
the biochemical state.
That being at the bottom of the
dominance hierarchy would produce.
In fact they're the same thing.
Well then the question is,
are you depressed or are you just at the
bottom of a dominance hierarchy because
those are not like the symptomatology is
very,
very similar,
but the cause and the cure are not the
same because you might be at the bottom
of a dominant Turkey because you just.
Everything about your life is ruined.
So,
and of course your suffering.
Are you depressed,
sir?
No,
not exactly.
You just have nowhere to go.